the economy is top of mind for
minorities here in Nevada so who are
they planning to support and what role
are unions playing in rallying non-white
voters
Las Vegas an entertainment Capital it
drew an average of 4 million visitors in
pre-pandemic times last year its
gambling industry generated more than 7
billion dollars in Revenue
behind the bright lights are tens of
thousands of workers many of whom are
minorities working in modestly paid jobs
in the casinos and hotels
Nevada's economic boom has made it a
magnet for immigrants
minority-owned Enterprises make up 36
percent of all business in the state
many are run by individuals from the
Latino Community during the pandemic
dandino Garcia opened up this Cafe
serving traditional Venezuelan fare and
it survived
but the costs of keeping it going in an
inflationary economy have been a stiff
challenge
price goes High because the inflation
for 20 bucks everybody's gonna be like a
what you know so that's the that's the
difficult plan between our expenses our
profit you know and the customers that
we want to make so all these three
things combine it is really difficult
dandino's main message to politicians
this election season reach a handout to
help immigrant businesses
but he's not sure if he's reaching a
hand back
in a big election year like this one
minorities are a coveted voting Bloc and
the president of Nevada's Latin Chamber
of Commerce Peter Guzman has been paying
close attention to the twists and turns
of the economy there's so much power in
voting but the real power in the vote is
not allowing any party to assume they
have you to have your vote come earn it
come earn it come sit down and talk to
these folks to these small businesses
it's not just small businesses
minorities have also built economic
clout by organizing joining powerful
labor unions that have provided a boost
for the Democrats and that's a trend
that's unlikely to change in Nevada
[Music]
so there is a narrative this cycle that
somehow Republicans are making inroads
with Latinos I think you have to be
careful with that because some of the
polling is National and what we see in
the National polls of just Latinos is
sometimes driven in a large part from
results from South Texas and also
principally from Florida so Latinos are
as you know are not a monolithic group
they are diverse and Latinos here have
different political orientations also
sometimes countries of origin compared
to places like Florida most here
identify as either coming from Mexico or
they're Mexican-American in terms of
their identity and they tend to have
more liberal orientations and align more
with the Democratic party
Latinos are also a central pillar of The
Culinary Workers Union it is the largest
private sector Union in Nevada with more
than sixty thousand members all workers
in Vegas's high octane casinos hotels
and restaurants
[Music]
Mercy Gonzalez and Aaron Rodriguez say
their Union has empowered them and
helped open doors
Mercy tells us she works as a porter in
the Paris Casino and Hotel and we're a
family it's us the Union
against them are our our employers so if
we have a problem we all get together
and together we're strong and we're
stronger than them you know so that's
what makes us powerful and obviously
peoples are politicians see it so that's
why they support us
The Culinary Workers Union runs huge
canvassing campaigns in Las Vegas to get
working-class voters to the polls
[Music]
it's ridiculous
stop we need to stop it so we're trying
to collect the signatures and make it
happen
rent prices are growing faster in Las
Vegas than almost anywhere else in the
U.S
the union wants rent increases capped at
five percent and they say Democrats can
deliver on that demand but it's not
always an easy sell especially as the
cost of living remains stubbornly High
the union secretary treasurer tells us
this election is going to be the closest
race ever but for working-class voters
he believes the choice is clear and its
Wall Street landlords that are buying up
homes buying up Apartments buying up
short-term rentals
and these are massive hedge funds that
are putting billions of dollars into
housing and and really taking it and
nobody really thinks Republicans are
going to take on Wall Street landlords
it's a similar
similar and other powerful Union which
represents workers in health care and
the public sector
the SEIU Local 1107 just reached its
goal of registering 10 000 new voters
ahead of the midterms
Grace Vergara magdal tells us a fourth
of the Union's members are part of
Nevada's thriving Asian American and
Pacific Islander or aapi Community
they've also endorsed the Democrats and
they've gotten a lot of attention in
return I was an adult when I came here
and I felt that invisibility because I
am an API and I am a woman of color so I
think it's not it's not going to change
overnight there's still going to be that
but the the fact that they are paying
attention to API I think it makes me
proud that the generations are not going
to be invisible anymore a view that we
hear reflected in Las Vegas's sprawling
Chinatown among the aapi business
Community the exciting thing about this
upcoming midterm is the Asian American
Pacific Islander voting block I call it
a new American Dream voting block will
be the margin of Victory it's up for
grabs so will minority voters really tip
the scale in these midterm elections in
Nevada the vote largely comes down to
the economy and unions will play a major
role in shaping the outcome but they
won't be the only ones deciding whether
their state is blue red or purple
[Music]